welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid if you're a details person you
might have noticed a book missing from
my shelf over here it's this book I've
been reading it to brush up on my
quantum physics you know for various
reasons so quantum has been in my mind
lately which would drive anyone crazy
quantum quantum quantum quantum quantum
what is quantum physics anyway in a word
crazy why I think it's time for a list
this is the top four craziest things
about quantum physics I should warn you
though these are gonna get so crazy that
by the end you probably won't believe me
anymore crazy thing number one electrons
can't go wherever they want they can
only go certain places called States or
orbitals different orbitals have
different shapes and sizes on top of
that you can only put at most two
electrons in each state they don't like
threesomes if an electron jumps from a
high to a low state that Energy's got to
go somewhere so it gets released as a
little packet of light called a photon
since electrons can only be certain
places they can only have certain
energies so the photons are always the
same for a certain type of atom it's
kind of like in a time of fingerprint
but we call it an atomic spectrum for
example this is hydrogen this is helium
and this is neon it's how we know what
the Sun is made of without ever having
taken a sample speaking of photons crazy
thing number two particles are waves and
waves are particles we call this wave
particle duality in the 1660s Isaac
Newton was convinced light was made of
little particles in 1801 Thomas young
showed that light was a wave then in
1913 Niels Bohr showed that light had to
also be a particle wait wait it's both
yep or maybe neither it's weird
so you can think of all beams of light
like lasers or flashlights as being made
of a bunch of little photons they're the
smallest piece of the beam just like
water molecules are for water fewer of
them means less light and more of them
means more light if something has a
smallest piece we say that it's
quantized and we call that smallest
piece a quantum and light isn't the only
thing that does this all of them do even
things like electrons show wave property
sometimes it's crazy so wait what about
an electron is waving the probability of
its existence great
thing number three quantum stuff happens
by pure chance as scientists we prefer
there to be some kind of cause and
effect this happened because this
happened but about a century ago we had
to let that go it's not really a photon
wave or an electron wave it's a
probability wave basically if we say
this is an electrons wave it's more
likely to exist here than it is to exist
here but it exists somewhere right
crazy thing number for measurement
screws everything up so you know there's
an electron somewhere in here then you
do an experiment and you're like there
it is naturally you'd like to also say
something like it's on this orbit so it
used to be here and it will eventually
be here but you can't the more you know
about where something is the less you
know about what it's doing it's called
the uncertainty principle to make
matters worse this isn't even about what
we know and what we don't know
experimental evidence suggests something
even weirder remember that electron you
measured before it didn't even really
have a position before you measured it
you gave it one the measurement just
gave you the illusion that you figured
something out I hate you quantum I hate
you so can you describe quantum physics
and ten words or less
let us know what you come up with in the
comments you know if your brain isn't
mushed by this point and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
got quantum quantum wanna